today on our show hold the door hold the
door who the do hold the door door we're
gonna love on Game of Thrones and the
season finale of flash on this very
episode of fat man on Batman
hello well we do another thrilling
episode The Fatman I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I'm workman Arden we are gonna
talk about two of the greatest hours of
TV produced this year fair enough
I will say definitely Game of Thrones
was a stunning episode this week this is
not the game of Thrones podcast but we
should talk about stuff like that on
this show we've given it love before we
have indeed but this is perhaps one of
the greatest hours of that series they
produced a course and ending with the
Hodor revelation and then spoilers just
like the rest of the show being watches
yet hold on don't [ __ ] listen to the
spoilers 1 2 3 the death of Hodor Oh dad
honestly dude I thought that
[ __ ] would make it to the end I
didn't think he'd sit on the Iron Throne
but I honestly thought like he'd make it
the eggs he had no agenda I thought he'd
bring me pick up there and throne and
bring it to somebody this is why you
[ __ ] hang out with [ __ ]
pumping the iron it's kinda like it's
kind of like the ending of brings it to
bran and he's like and then some wheels
on it to push brain and the wheel iron
wheels
oh my god they did a phenomenal job
without the help of Mark Bernard if you
believe that man they wrote a [ __ ]
killer episode gave us a lot of
information including the origin of the
white walkers which they throw away like
you would be like hey did you see you
know it's safe 78 degrees out today he's
tossed it away you're like nope just I
pushed a thing in a dude White Walkers
and that's it and that's enough [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying like you don't
have to do three episodes about that it
was just like forget it they were using
this guy turning them into a white
Walker to protect them from the humans
yep
oops yeah whoops yeah I will tell you
though fire away I love this episode
save one thing Oh
the one thing I don't love I was talking
to our producer Matt key about this
before I am Not sure that I need
time-travel peanut butter in my Game of
Thrones chocolate explain because of
brand were logging into the past
badass I'm like he worked minimum 30
years into the future from a flashback
was he in the past I understand warning
is he literally there according to the
three eye Raven technology which clearly
has been found out by the finest minds
of Westeros yes like I I have no problem
at all with time travel yeah as long as
you it's baked into your show from the
beginning like a lost is fundamentally
about time travel
it is like flash forwards and flashbacks
sideways like temporal fluidity is is in
that DNA this was like time travel yeah
I thought I was supposed to just by
magic like you get the one box yeah
don't get shitty where you're like what
I believe in the magic and the dragons
and the Stoneskin but time travel [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
no time for your time travel it's just
jump the [ __ ] shark yeah or whatever
these shark equivalent to dragon this is
in the game joke the King shark that's
me didn't bother me I thought that was
kind of bad oh [ __ ] especially the fact
that he created brand created Hodor
mmm-hmm that's yeah thanks right you
know I was gonna live a perfectly happy
fat life until brands like who do Ellis
his name was and he was like chatty and
sure he was a what is Willis talking
about yeah everything what you talking
about Willis just go oh [ __ ] do you
think that moment what created do you
just give him a stroke because he was
using his mind or was it Hodor
young Hodor through the eyes of old
Hodor sees his own death terrifies him
to death and that's what makes him like
maybe well he would always freak out
when there's lightning and [ __ ] like
that like he was easily scared and
that's what I what I was watching I was
like oh my god do they mean that he's
[ __ ] known forever in the back of his
mind this is how it goes out it was
badass dude him holding that [ __ ]
door so much so that shows always well
shot well cut well scored but there was
one cut to him like bearing down on the
door that made me
[ __ ] really cry where he was just
like no like you know door hold yeah no
door he was but like really trying then
when the [ __ ] axes came through like
cuz I was sitting there gone don't kill
this [ __ ] like no way you can't not
him not this far oh my god as soon as
the [ __ ] the axis came through and
the hands that are scraping him and
stabbing him
it's [ __ ] balling it and I knew to
the moment he was she goes hold the door
I was like no lawyers character one of
the only characters in television
history said one [ __ ] in all of his
episodes it's like a bunk from the wire
doing the [ __ ] but for five seasons it
was it was perhaps some of the finest
storytelling ever producing I watched
the after the show that they do behind
the scenes and those two producer dudes
they talked about getting that from the
source anyone any often why said we
talked to George Martin we were trying
to pull information out of him in a
hotel room it sounds very sick yes he's
paid me like you paid your French is he
told them that origin story and they
were like they didn't said it cry but
they were like even in the room moving I
tested this is grab put up on Twitter I
was like fantastic storytelling doesn't
need [ __ ] pictures to travel my kid
don't watch Game of Thrones I was
driving her to work the next day I told
her the [ __ ] story of Hodor in terms
of like you know I had to give a little
back and like he only says old [ __ ] like
that's about all the backstory needs I
only says older then I'm like here's why
he says so to her I told that story dude
she's [ __ ] bawling mmm bawling like
and I'm like you gotta watch this show
she's a guy because holy but she watched
it just today I was the show to the
scene cuz my wife was like your
daughter's here crying about hold the
door or something because I was telling
her about muggle Game of Thrones hold on
that brought her down into the room and
showed her that whole sequence and she
was like like audible I love that I was
like this because definitely my god
screaming at the TV for somebody she
didn't even have a connection to I've
watched many seasons so I like Hodor but
I also got her with flash to us driving
her to school today at the bus stop and
I told her this is the ending of the
season finale and that got her crying
too man like that's good storytelling
when you can like be like oh you know
what they did last night you tell it to
somebody and they're like oh my god
that's affecting me and I don't even
watch it yeah so good what else did you
like in the episode like Sansa that's
relax
[ __ ] awesome where she's just like
let's take back the north and also did
you know ramsey Littlefinger did you now
top with him she's like saying say what
he did to me I don't know what he did to
me that was [ __ ] good they like you
know for years her character of course
first time we ever saw her she was
selling mm-hm and then next time we
first time we seen in this episode she's
sewing and then gives to Jon Snow it is
[ __ ] good the wolf the wolf in cities
but yeah they let her like light up
especially they're like Santa's here
like a [ __ ] man and that seemed
Littlefinger was hands down her best
work in the show it's not taking
anything away a good long while it's not
saying she's never been good she's
wonderful but [ __ ] that's like like now
you can't go backwards after that scene
she's become like instantly drops jumps
to the top ten most interesting people
on Game of Thrones
yeah totally I mean especially between
like last week where she just the Sansa
story of her finally getting to hug Jon
like I have never having seen him for
like five years of this show but I think
I'm on camera together hardly a season
one I really interact I mean they might
have been in the hey the king is coming
to Winterfell scene and that's kind of
it
so the we're finally getting what we
want out of Sansa we're getting her like
reunited with her potentially possibly
not at all brother oh my god give me a
single he's [ __ ] wrong yeah maybe
uncle no because there was this whole
theory that he is not the bastard son of
Ned Stark ed stark he is the bastard
fort spoilers spoilers one two three
spoiler of Lissa who is Kat Stark's
sister and Targaryen dude so that Tower
of joy Tower
you know young Ned Stark killed a
[ __ ] rhaegar targaryen I think and
Alyssa whatever her name is and they
it's not like they made it seem like it
was the attacker and like a record but
we all think that it's they were in love
and had a baby and that baby's John Snow
and apparently in the books there is
this whole scene where they they get to
the tower and the bed is covered in
blood and they never speak of it again
but the blood is like childbirth dies in
childbirth nobody stops for a second go
hey there was a baby born here it's real
[ __ ] don't tell me that Game of Thrones
is predicated on a Three's Company that
only someone had told fir away the jack
was not gay what happened what else
happened in that show man co fian
finally it turns into a man without a
balls yeah can you imagine for the rest
of your life everyone in towns like
where's your coke you can't speak for
the Ironborn you go look okay got no
iron in your deck cuz you're gonna Jack
God took Kurt everyone's got a closer to
a fight with anybody even if you're
fully justified you can't get it to a
fight how's your dick doing yeah hey
[ __ ] you've got something to say
look I guess not
well I am it's the truth but you know
you put that dude down long enough
sooner or later [ __ ] he's gonna start
cutting clothes yeah [ __ ] man got
nothing to lose mark I know that's my
whole life is predicated on that I'm a
[ __ ] man I've done many things
braved heading out and to adventure
because I'm like what do I got to lose
certainly not a dick
same thing with Fionna I mean clearly
[ __ ] men in this world can be on the
rise you ain't Lord Varys that's
actually very funny who has a bigger
dick the honor sister at this point Oh
sister I'd say she's ready to rule she
was about to be queen and [ __ ] she was
like I [ __ ] clay in the iron throne
and then uncle killer called your honor
his name in urine yurina he's just
pissing all over everything like with
your inhalation urine and suddenly
that's it suddenly it was [ __ ] up man
I like to drown the ceremony that makes
somebody the [ __ ] cake
the Ironborn and [ __ ] where l suddeniy
drowns and literally [ __ ] drowns him
if the dude comes back to life he's the
kid but you win holy [ __ ] and the first
thing he says it's like where my niece
and nephew let's kill them so thank God
they [ __ ] took half of the fleet
maybe they knew how that was gonna go
down yeah and boy they had a lot of
people on their side pretty much that's
the thing you see all those boats
sailing away it's just like you know of
all those people turn around and said
we're gonna stand by her here on the
shore and kill you they probably could
have taken over all uncle your bubbly
and the old man priest who's like it's a
clergyman [ __ ] [ __ ] up last season of
a shame the [ __ ] water priests clergy
that's what else we got hook up the meme
that will never stop me me it's kind of
awesome man and she's like no way just
because you're tall doesn't mean I have
to [ __ ] you six foot five and worth the
climb in the books apparently he brags
of betting a she-bear big character
there's a large man that's one of those
things that I support large people
getting together those people aren't fat
they're tall if they go to the wide and
tall store if they're going to the tall
side it's pretty much I'm on the other
side of the store do all those [ __ ]
are tall they're on the other side the
store going he's in the fat section
rest well and dream of logic winning oh
yeah oh yeah that show he goes to the
theater
holy [ __ ] could you imagine you go see a
[ __ ] play and they show a play of
your life to make sure dad ass be a dick
an [ __ ] comedy of your tragedy life
identified he's like the dummy character
and she's just sitting there now and she
could smoke all these fools but she can
cause she nobody know a girl has no name
that's right a girl likes to go to the
theater she was set there because she's
supposed to kill the actress which he
don't she want to do yet but while she's
there she has to [ __ ] watch that [ __ ]
doesn't make me want to kill not just
the actress but every bucket out there
holy [ __ ] burned it to the ground
- this [ __ ] show continues to deliver
these two dudes are [ __ ] geniuses man
yeah here's Weiss Anthony off yeah DB
Weiss and Dan video Jesus who'll
honestly man like [ __ ] who looks at
those books and goes it's a [ __ ] show
there it is
those guys that's why they get the
[ __ ] make it rain for them fools and
George RR Martin's man it's crazy dude
like I'm sitting there watching [ __ ]
fairy people throwing hand grenades of
dead people this is my [ __ ] soap
opera Jam it this is real this is art so
fantastic episode of Game of Thrones
let's jump to the season finale of der
flash de flushing - flash when I
directed a few weeks ago know if you'd
know that but I've heard tell he was in
the Speed Force and he learned a very
important lesson but in the Speed Force
he met with many people and the person
the Speed Force looked like people is
life but the most important one of
course was his mother
so Barry's already compromised even
though everyone's like he learned so
much in your episode how could this have
happened in the final episode season for
now it's because Barry is emotional you
know Barry's not called logic like
Batman Barry Allen feels everything and
he don't think before he feels and you
know he's been this instrument of good
since he got his speed and the universe
keeps [ __ ] and taken from him and
taken from so in this season finale they
wrap up the zoom storyline and we got a
view of the black flash as he died I was
pretty badass you know that rapped very
well and they wrapped it like like last
season finale they took it right up to
the credits dude like as soon as he got
back from sitting not saving his mom and
then he beats Thawne the singularity
opens yeah and he's like drop us on the
ground and he [ __ ] runs up to stop it
this year's season finale was incredibly
emotional yeah
at the end it's just oh that was worth
the journey because it's not only strong
writing because you realize his kids
broken in my episode he saw his mom and
you know made some peace there with the
death of his mom the very next episode
spoilers his dad gets killed
so right arrays oh my he's already on
the ropes and stuff then he defeats zoom
you know the help of the team everybody
gets involved in the feat zoom and stuff
and so suddenly things are kind of back
to normal but in this quiet moment were
yeah as the scene with iris yes all show
they've been waiting everybody's waiting
for Barry and iris to kiss and they did
once in the two-shot they did once in
the day that didn't happen Barry reset
it this is only a second time they've
kissed and shown they did kiss and iris
tells him she's like I'm ready like do
this and Barry says like shockingly he's
like I'm right now I'm just not there
because of everything he's going through
so you're like oh they're pulling the
taffy on that relationship I salute them
man like they're finding every good
reason not to put him together
and it all makes sense like it all feels
founded it's not inauthentic no it's
real and stuff so she's like I'm all she
said she he goes I got to work on some
things and she goes we'll all be here
for you just like you were always there
for me for all those years I'm gonna
wait for you Barry and the kiss it's
[ __ ] astounding she goes in the house
and then there's this really sad moment
where he looks at them in the house and
he's like pot they can't hear him
buddy's like I'm sorry but I have to do
this because he knows he knows what he's
about to do is not what he's supposed to
do but he so much has been taken from
Barry charges into the speed for into
the creates a time old goes back in time
let's put it that way um go so fast he
goes back in time which he knows now how
to do very easily goes back to the
moment just like in the season finale
focuses on the moment of his mother's
death gets to the house just as his
mom's about to be killed he sees the
Lightning going on from the outside the
other version of himself gets young
Barry out of the house so that eobard
thawne the reverse-flash can't kill him
and so the reverse-flash of course kills
Barry's mom instead but justice like
reverse-flash grabs a knife and they cut
to his mom Michelle Harrison flew back
he's about to stab her [ __ ] BAM Barry
comes to the window like a [ __ ] hero
just slide tackles that [ __ ]
takes him down and he's just like he
beats the [ __ ] I'm he's like you're
never gonna kill her yeah he's like
you never gonna kill her he goes y'all
gonna kill his time you're never gonna
kill her again Bam Bam Bam [ __ ] takes
I was hoping he was just like that would
have been amazed if he was like no it
took me [ __ ] hard ass since daddy's
here he just beat the [ __ ] up and should
throw him to the ground essentially
saving his mother yes mother's all
scared and he's like you're safe you're
safe and that's how the [ __ ] episode
ended which anybody who knows their
comic books mm-hmm that's the beginning
of flashpoint right there if you've seen
the cartoon and read the comic books the
cartoon was the flashpoint paradox comic
books was flashpoint Barragan bag you
can't [ __ ] with time Stephen King tell
ya I'm will [ __ ] with you so Barry did
thing he shouldn't have done any new he
shouldn't have done because emotional
he's emotional he's broken he also let's
not forget killed himself in this
episode which is he creates the time
double of himself which zoom did in the
beginning of zoomed in the beginning
episode he says well you know what
happened to that other guy it's like
well that other person was me another
person killed himself like we're the
same guy but I just made that decision
that in order for me to survive in order
for you to survive I was willing to die
and I did like he was in the place in
the headspace where he was willing to
kill himself right that breaks a dude
yeah
good Paul couldn't you see I watched the
last 10 minutes you watched all of them
you're absolutely right on that point
yeah like that's that's the thing that
kind of any he just doesn't want to hurt
anymore like he's spent his entire life
not being selfish right like sacrifices
at the core of being hero he sacrifices
everything all the time he just wants
missing all of [ __ ] just like you know
what I don't want to sacrifice anymore
like I just want to be whole again like
everything that I've got everything that
I am has been ripped from me the only
way for me to be whole is to sacrifice
all of you and that's the choice he
makes cuz he knows that after he does
this Irish isn't in his life that way no
wasn't in his life now what do you think
happens with iris do you think he'd
think about it so if Barry comes back
and his mom didn't die and then time
didn't happen the way it did
iris is maybe probably with eddie thawne
yeah he's not dead so they could bring
him back cuz if if Nora Allen's not
killed the timeline gets crazy as cute
as we know in the comics it goes
incredible places
when including Thomas Wayne as the
Batman like in that version of the story
you know since Barry changed time
everything going forward was changed
created the new 52 universe over at DC
but one of the big things was Thomas
Wayne and Martha Wayne and the alley Joe
Chill didn't kill them he killed the boy
Bruce Wayne dies and that drives the
father to become Batman even [ __ ]
better it drove the mom to become the
Joker yeah that was so [ __ ] amazing
that is also as an adjunct to the
flashpoint like miniseries and stuff now
I don't know if they could do that
because they did historically over in
Berlanti land they don't let him play
with Batman or Superman Wonder Woman the
Trinity but that's that's Thomas Wayne
and Martha Wayne that's not Bruce Bruce
is then only referenced as a little boy
I would break the law if I was DC and
Warner Brothers going like that is movie
stuff I'd be like come on they're
[ __ ] doing Batman on Fox and it's a
little boy you telling me we can't do
not even Batman Bruce Wayne Thomas Wayne
his parents and Martha Wayne ain't
nobody jockeying to get those characters
like I want to get them next like nobody
cares about them I hope they bring them
in I hope but lanty should have enough
juice at this point man he's got they
just added CW Supergirl to the CW's was
practically DCW at this point it's got
four comic book shows coming into this
season dude you've got complaints from
some of the other shows or why not
anybody's like wow this character is
missing this gives them a chance to like
reboot the universe with the storyline
that doing flashpoints down you know or
they do it they do that stuff to arrow
like they turn it into like arrows dad
is arrow and Stephen Amell isn't like he
doesn't survive the island like there's
all of those you know the sliding doors
versions of the universe imagine they do
that across all the shows I mean they
should that's how they're going to
incorporate Supergirl into the sort of
CW Prime universe like this is their
reset for that she's no longer on a
different planet and he/she was earth 3
before ya know she's [ __ ] here because
if you don't have a Supergirl flash
crossover every eight episodes then
you're an idiot
the other thing I loved in this episode
I thought was really [ __ ] emotional
was you know one of the greatest moments
of last season finale Berry is about to
go in and save his mother and then
suddenly the version of him that's
already there goes like this and says no
and berry-like reacts and doesn't do it
and his mom gets killed so here he goes
back in this season fell to the exact
same moment and stops the reverse-flash
and then he looks and the door opens and
the it was season one version of Barry
in that moment
yeah and Barry looks down he sees his
mom's alive and he has this like grand
had a perfect reaction we get all
[ __ ] emotional but he had this
[ __ ] relief and that's the guy from
season one the one who was like I have
to go back here because [ __ ] eobard
thawne is about to go back in time to
his time and this is my only chance I
got a minute and change to go back and
stop my mother from being killed so he
sees his mom alive and he has this
relief on his face and he hasn't kind of
like chuckling and then he disappears
which is [ __ ] up cuz that means our
Barry that we've been following since
the pilot since arrow or whatever the
[ __ ] has officially died mm-hmm that
Barry died disappeared in the doorway so
back to the future Polaroid version of
Dom tree you went away like the sister
like Wendy Jo Sperber he's gone man or a
[ __ ] Jimmy Olsen in that movie Doug
he was in that movie too so it's that
that to me was like wow they'd already
played with the time remnant thing
earlier in the show where you're like
well it's not him but it is him totally
is so in that moment they killed the
Barry that we all grew up with for that
one year and change all the way up to
that moment in time but that is
especially that [ __ ] Barry man like
that broke my heart not not in a way
where I'm like I [ __ ] up I was like
that is so rich that is so incredibly
[ __ ] deep like that little boy who
was hurt by the death of his mom he got
to see some closure before he just
blinked out of [ __ ] existence I do
look forward to the scene which will
have to come at some point where there's
like 87 flashes in that [ __ ] house
we go for each other forever big deal
this I got this you got this I got this
real good right mom mom no go yes maybe
they pitched flash as the time-travel
show mmm like you never would have liked
I when you know they said flash the TV
show he runs real fast and [ __ ] but
literally you get to do with this you
get to do time travel because it's
science
like you'd as we talked about in Game of
Thrones that for me time travel wasn't
baked into that bin Bush knows about
magic which I guess you can time check
out the magic but whatever this is
science and this is fake sighs this is
like Cisco making [ __ ] up because it
sounds cool sighs if you're on this
patch they'll go up the wall they're
reversing the polarity yeah learn to
make a thrust of the catatonic particle
those were smarter than my words surely
abused it's it's checking the tech yeah
he's Willy used to call him a Star Trek
it doesn't matter because it's science
its Sciences how the works and they they
use it to such a devastating effect you
don't mind and it's why I didn't mind it
that much in Game of Thrones because
it's used to such a devastating effect
look some people use time travel and
they [ __ ] wasted or whatever Game of
Thrones used it expertly this yes I feel
flash I mean we've yet to see season
three but for a jumping-off point for a
season finale like how do you top last
year's season finale in the last five
minutes of their episode they were able
to stand shoulder-to-shoulder with that
very powerful episode to be like
everything you know is now about to
[ __ ] change where is it but it has to
it will its flash point yeah so that
means you get a whole [ __ ] season 23
episodes to like [ __ ] up the world man
like there's like think about it he
could go back not have his powers is he
no longer the flash at that point his
mom doesn't die maybe all that other
[ __ ] doesn't happen but Wally can be the
flash so you know how they didn't do
Wally last season everyone's like when's
he gonna get his powers maybe when we
come back Wally is the flash Jesse quick
is Jesse quick and Barry's the one who's
powerless because he was powerless in in
at one point he gets stabbed to the leg
and in flashpoint paradox Ruby and
Batman had to like get him his power
back recreate the experiment she liked
that his science
sokka's science um oh my god what a
great [ __ ] two hours of television is
better than smoke in movies certainly
better than ever Kevin Smith movie but
Oh better than a lot of movies except
for like Civil War like so rich so says
wonderful performances great Direction
fantastic production design excellent
writing it all begins with excellent
writing you heard why that writing was
so excellent on the page maps then on
page down the stage and it rhymes and
arise that's goddamn rhyme so it's
member pneumonic son there it is man we
talked about Game of Thrones we talked
about flash now we got to talk about
getting out of here man we're gonna
disappear like Barry in the doorway
after her mom is saved by another flash
there's a metaphor an analogy where
it'll probably get you later for fat man
I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm Oprah
Nora come back and see us next time same
fat time same channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
a man's meat Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder